ne regarde pas ça viens ici d'accord on
doit en parler de toute façon je fais ça
pour toi tu veux boire à chaque fois qu'est ce que
tu te demandes à chaque fois pas le droit alors je
te dis ce que nous devons faire nous avons
pour parler de pic oh bon d'accord, donc je
sais que vous avez une signification différente
pour le titre à chaque fois que vous posez des questions,
alors cette fois je vous pose des questions sur la signification
de spider directement moi quelle est
votre interprétation d'aujourd'hui c'est
juste le titre  du disque, c'est le
nom de celui-ci, certaines personnes
s'appellent Jared, ce disque s'appelle Spike
non seulement les noms, il y a eu
un assez grand écart entre celui-ci ethine
Spike et les albums précédents deux ans
et demi quelque chose alors que s'est-il passé
entre-temps  toutes sortes de
trucs que j'ai fait pendant que j'écrivais les chansons
évidemment ça a pris du temps et
entre-temps j'ai aussi collaboré
avec différentes personnes Ruben blades j'ai
fait quelques chansons avec lui pour son
disque en anglais j'ai fait un  chanson par mail
commander avec aimee mann du au mardi
bien sûr j'ai écrit des chansons avec
paul mccartney été qui a conduit à son
disque et quelques chansons qui ont conduit
au mien et ma femme et moi avons vécu à
Dublin pendant quelques mois alors qu'elle était dans
un film appelé  Le Courrier et moi avons fait la
bande originale de cela, donc dans l'ensemble,
même si ce n'était pas vraiment aux yeux du public
, j'ai fait quelques petites tournées et en
Australie et au Japon dans les États
du sud de l'Amérique avec un répertoire très spécifique
pas le genre de  promouvoir n'importe quel
disque particulier, sorte de continuation
du disque du roi d'Amérique où j'ai
joué avec certaines des personnes qui ont
joué sur cet album, donc beaucoup de
choses que j'ai faites étaient juste que je suivais
des offres intéressantes qui m'ont été faites
qui n'ont pas '  Cela n'a nécessairement rien à
voir avec l'avancement de ma carrière en tant que
pop star dominante dans le monde.
Vous ne connaissez pas vraiment mon ambition dans la vie.
s sound go a
dit qu'il fallait s'emballer cette fois
non je prévoyais de le rendre aussi
vivant que possible l'instrumentation était à
peu près choisie à l'avance et nous avons
prévu de quitter les endroits où
ces musiciens étaient nous avons travaillé à
Dublin  certains travaux à la Nouvelle-Orléans et le
reste à Los Angeles et à Londres et
bien que cela semble très grand, c'était
vraiment juste une question pratique d'aller
là où c'est le moins cher de travailler avec les
musiciens plutôt que de faire voler tous ces
musiciens à grands frais à l'
autre bout du monde vous  je sais donc
nous trois produisant le disque moi-même Kevin
killin t-bone Burnett c'était beaucoup plus facile
pour nous de passer d'un studio à l'
autre pour déplacer les musiciens euh chaque chanson était en quelque
sorte coulée si vous aimez, vous savez qu'il y
avait une histoire impliquée  et la musique que j'ai
ressentie cette fois-ci nécessitait au moins un
éclairage à l'aide de différents instruments
et que j'utilisais dans le passé je
n'ai pas entendu les sons sur ma tête que
vous avez trouvés dans la guitare conventionnelle  r la
gamme de grosses caisses et de claviers dans tous les
cas, certaines des chansons comme celle-ci sonnent, d'
autres incorporent les tuyaux
et les fanfares Dylan de Mizuki et mais ce n'est pas ce
n'était pas juste une question d'
attendre pour réfléchir aux raisons d'utiliser ce
son que j'ai pensé au  sonne d'abord,
puis a trouvé les gens qui ont fait le mieux
mais beaucoup de gens dans le four il n'y a
pas d'attraction donc Pete est ce qui s'est passé
Pete Thomas joue de la batterie sur quelques
choses oui bien parce que pour cette
raison même c'était alors je n'ai pas entendu  ce
son, je n'ai pas entendu le son que nous produisons,
vous devez comprendre que le
son du groupe ne dépend pas seulement
des instruments qu'ils jouent, il dépend
de qui sont ces gens et de leur
relation les uns avec les autres, avec moi et
avec  mes chansons et ces choses changent tout
le temps donc quiconque a une
attirance nostalgique ou sentimentale cet
attachement aux attractions c'est peut-être
un peu faux parce qu'ils ne sont pas
ce qu'ils imaginent ils sont tous différents
le temps où nous serions différents
chaque année, nous avons tous
changé de personnes et donc ce n'est pas
quelque chose de prêt à l'emploi
que vous savez qui vit dans une boîte
quelque part que vous pouvez sortir et
qui reste toujours constant  vous savez que nous sommes des
individus et donc nous changeons
nos attitudes pour réutiliser le compte l'un de l'
autre et à cette occasion particulière j'ai
choisi de travailler avec des personnes différentes
bien s'ils ne sont que des personnages arrêtez bien
Jason ouais d'accord donc ils ne sont qu'elle
premier single on m'a fait appeler du bruit
autour du monde mec vous avez été surpris
par le bateau du succès compte tenu de sa
renommée et des poids bien traités
c'était une sorte d'appareil délibéré
que la chaise sonnerait
superficiellement comme si c'était quelque chose
sujet très joyeux et en fait assez
sérieux et c'est l'
appareil que j'utilise le passé et bave
ce n'est pas tout à fait original et si les
gens l'ont fait vous avez le choix
entre vous savez avec la musique de l'un ou l'autre  r
reflétant exactement les paroles et le ciel
sait qu'il y a beaucoup de chansons qui sont
complètement vides dans les sentiments et
la musique est convenablement appropriée et dans
ce cas j'ai choisi de contraster le fait que
la musique est très légère et
j'espère qu'elle contient du sens  d'espoir
que la chanson a même si elle traite
de l'esprit de la femme qui vagabonde à mesure qu'elle
vieillit ouais je sais vraiment qu'il
y a quelque chose d'
extraordinaire dans une chanson qui est bien
construite pour atteindre les gens en tant qu'élément musical,
que cela ait ou non le même
sens de  tout le monde c'est à l'
individu que vous savez que leur choix
n'implose pas les gens n'écoutent pas
ce que vous dites non ce n'est pas vrai
parce que j'ai trouvé que vous savez très très très
agréable de trouver cela et le cours
des voyages récemment  envoyé en Amérique, je
serais sur une compagnie aérienne allant quelque part, vous
savez, pour le prochain concert et quelqu'un
comme ça, l'hôtesse de l'air,
m'interrogerait soudainement et détaillerait
la chanson, même le  l'agent d'immigration la
dernière fois que je suis allé en Amérique a
dit alors c'est ainsi dans le pont de
Veronica êtes-vous en train de dire que vous savez que je veux dire des
choses comme ça prouve que vous savez que les
gens font juste leur
travail ordinaire et l'entendent à la
radio retiennent les choses  c'est une erreur je veux dire
trop de problème est de savoir qui parle aux
gens que vous connaissez ce n'est pas très
haut vol je veux dire ce que je dis n'est pas
une grande déclaration philosophique c'est
juste une histoire simple j'ai juste choisi de la
mettre à la place  de dans de la musique très sombre dans de la
musique joyeuse de sony
Oh encore ça j'étais dans l'autre fois
mais quand j'ai quitté son armée a été un grand
succès encore une fois ce très bon c'était
le même appareil ouais je veux dire comme je dis
comment nous l'avons utilisé plusieurs fois  eh bien, il
y a un célibataire possible peut-être en retard dans
cette ville, eh bien, c'est peut-être ça, vous
savez, je veux dire que vous pouvez marcher dans n'importe quelle rue
n'importe où en Angleterre et ici
, des enfants de huit ans utilisant un langage
qui offenserait un vicaire que vous connaissez et il
semble que certains pouvoirs  aurait
un problème avec le mot bâtard ça va
bâtards un fait de la vie vous savez et le
but de la chanson n'est pas d'
indigner qui que ce soit en utilisant le mot car
cela arrive juste au titre complet de
la chanson  est votre personne dans cette ville
jusqu'à ce que tout le monde pense que vous êtes un bâtard Je
crois que c'est un credo auquel
certaines personnes souscrivent ces jours-ci et
la chanson est et un ridicule pas si doux
de cette attitude Je ne vois aucun problème
avec  qu'avec cela exprimé, je
pense que c'est probablement bien pour les gens d'
avoir une chanson à ce sujet parce que c'est si
répandu mais il y a certains pouvoirs
qui sont que vous savez avoir peur d'
offenser leur tante ou quelque chose qui
semble avoir un problème qui
pourrait empêcher  c'est que tu sais ou
exposé dans tous les médiums qui
auraient espéré que ce soit je veux dire tu as volé ma
question je veux dire j'étais un doigt j'aime le
pouvoir le pouvoir des mots aimez-vous
comme mettre le bus plus tôt d'un refrain
sais ce que je  veux dire qu'est-ce que tu sais  w si
je le faisais juste un magasin d'armes, ce
serait un peu vide parce que ce n'est pas
vraiment choquant tu sais je veux dire
c'est le mot pour ça ce serait
le mot pour décrire le genre de personne
qui est décrit dans la chanson vous
sais que tu pourrais utiliser un autre euphémisme pour
eux tu sais mais j'ai choisi celui-là
je ne l'utilisais pas car un fait qui
semble juste être dans un programme me semble assez
doux tu sais j'aurais pu utiliser
un langage beaucoup plus dur tu sais que nous avons utilisé
c'est dans le plaisir des mots et le
plaisir d'utiliser des mots pour offenser eh bien
ils sont censés juste exprimer quelque chose
qu'ils ne sont pas vraiment ils ne sont pas vraiment
pour l'effet ils ne sont pas affectés par la
même chose donc il devrait y avoir ce que vous
pensez  à propos de vous savez que vous essayez de trouver
les mots pour exprimer vos sentiments ou
ce que vous observez, alors laissez-les seuls a
actuellement réagi à la chanson du thon J'ai bien fait don de
ma peau Je vous demande maintenant comment a-t-
il pesé de quelle manière bien dans le
contenu lyrique je  ne pense pas que nous ayons jamais
enregistré  Je veux dire que je l'ai utilisé, je veux dire, il était le
bassiste sur le suivi, je veux dire que vous ne
discutez pas toujours de tout en détail,
que vous vous connaissiez, vous n'avez pas à
aimer quand vous faites un gros opéra à cheval,
vous savez comme avec des soldats si romains.  vous
savez, comme dans un film, vous ne demandez pas au gars
à l'arrière qui tient la bannière, vous savez
pourquoi ils ont poignardé César, vous savez, je veux dire,
ce n'est pas important de savoir, donc à cet
égard, il est venu juste faire un travail de base,
alors vous savez qu'il  ne le
chantait pas ou quoi que ce soit donc je ne vois pas que nous
n'avons pas remis en question la boîte à rythmes qui
joue le rythme dans une machine à neige dites-nous
ce que le bâtard signifie pour vous vous savez que c'est
sans importance d'oublier s'est avéré être les
détails en collaboration quoi exactement
C'était la collaboration avec McCartney,
eh bien, il s'agit d'une douzaine de chansons
à tous les niveaux de
contribution de chaque côté. Nous avons
commencé avec moi en quelque sorte en écrivant les paroles
d'une chanson qu'il avait déjà commencé à
enregistrer.
ce  apparaissent sur
mon album, puis nous avons continué une fois que nous avons pris
la mesure de la technique de l'autre, nous
avons pu procéder assez rapidement pour
écrire un tas de chansons dont quatre
apparaissent sur des mouches sur la terre, donc je pense
qu'il y en a vous savez qu'elles  Ce sont de très
bonnes chansons, il y a aussi quelques très
bonnes chansons qui ne sont pas
encore apparues, alors qui peut les faire en tant que
discussion ouverte, celle qui rend ce terme
bien n'était pas exactement que McCormick a fait sur moi
à cette époque ouais hé, joue juste  la basse,
je veux dire qu'il était en fait la dernière personne à
jouer sur le morceau, je veux dire que beaucoup de ces
morceaux ont été construits sur une période de
temps en raison de la disponibilité des
musiciens et vous ne pouviez pas toujours planifier
comment les morceaux s'emboîteraient  certains
des enregistrements comme ceux faits en
Irlande ont été faits à peu près tous en
même temps ceux que nous avons faits dans votre objectif
ont été faits comme ça maintenant certains des
trucs que nous avons enregistrés à Los
Angeles ont été enregistrés sur peut-être
quelques mois  en raison du moment où pe  ople est devenu
disponible et dans le cas de cette fois,
nous avons
Gwen venu mettre la guitare à 12 cordes
dessus la première semaine de l'enregistrement
et la toute dernière semaine de l'enregistrement,
nous étions de retour à Londres et Paul
McCartney est venu dans la base alors il
terminé l'image jusque-là,
le morceau que vous connaissez a terminé le saumon
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de basse dessus lui oh l'avez-
vous fait quand il collaborera pour travailler
avec McCartney pour l'utiliser dès que je le
ferai en tant que chanteur c'est pourquoi il est un grand
la facilité arrive c'est un super chanteur tu
sais et j'ai chanté un peu sur son
disque mais j'avais déjà fait toutes les
parties vocales que tu sais je lui ai demandé de
faire la base et c'est ce qu'il tu sais
il jouait de la basse sur deux pistes mais je  Je veux dire que
c'est parce que nous avons collaboré sur des chansons
que sa contribution en tant que musicien a tendance à être
disproportionnée par rapport à la
contribution des autres musiciens, ce qui
était tout aussi important pour les deux
morceaux que je ne minimise pas. J'étais très content
qu'il soit venu et il  a fait une unique  travail
parce qu'il a un style unique de jeu de
la basse mais nous ne devrions pas mettre sa
contribution moi, vous savez, en tant
qu'instrumentiste hors de proportion avec
tous les autres qui ont joué sur le disque,
vous savez simplement parce qu'il est plus célèbre
que beaucoup d'entre nous dans et  en tant qu'auteur-
compositeur, cela vous exciterait-il de gagner quand
McCarley vous tromperait essentiellement au
bureau, eh bien, c'est un défi comme ça
comme tout comme je l'ai dit que les deux
années avant que je ne monte vraiment en flèche étaient une série
de défis différents et pas
tous si chargé  avec une signification apparente car
tout le monde semble penser que ce n'est
toujours que deux personnes assises dans une pièce
essayant d'écrire de bonnes chansons de la
même manière que lorsque j'écrivais
avec des lames de Ruben, vous savez, ou avec n'importe quel
homme ou avec ma femme flic  qui a écrit une
des chansons de l'album et j'ai juste mis un
peu de vous savez mon genre de cordes
derrière vous connaissez sa mélodie ouais ce
genre d'accord que vous faites avec McCullough sur
son album c'est assez incroyable le  un
quand tu n'es pas swimbait quand tu sais
ouais ouais ouais c'est assez incroyable
vérifie j'aime que cette chanson soit bien sur son bon
fils et puis sur la même piste
fait que jouer à la série de guitares à 12 cordes
est quelques résumés de toi donc j'ai
exactement  c'est arrivé quand il est
arrivé et je l'ai rencontré à la Nouvelle-
Orléans alors que nous travaillions avec la
fanfare de la douzaine sale et je suis
venu quelques semaines plus tard pour faire un
spectacle à Los Angeles et je l'ai invité
à jouer  sur la piste parce que je n'ai pas
vraiment décidé qui jouerait de la guitare
à ce terme et
il semblait avoir le son parfait mais
je ne l'ai pas vu jouer ou quoi que ce soit depuis plusieurs années donc je n'avais aucun moyen de savoir comment ça
sonnerait mais il l'a fait  un travail très très
imaginatif parce qu'il y avait il y
avait très peu sur le morceau quand il
jouait qu'il y avait juste ma voix et ma
guitare acoustique sur une boîte à rythme et
le tu connais le livre ouais tu sais les
oiseaux se reforment alors qu'est-ce
que tu ferais  pense que tu es  va bien
faire qu'est-ce que tu en penses d'après
ce que je comprends c'est pour
défendre leur nom parce qu'il était
approprié par des gens qui étaient peut-
être dans le groupe depuis 10 minutes et et
les vrais membres fondateurs de  le
groupe en quelque sorte risquait de
perdre les droits du nom et je
pense que cela pourrait être très
intéressant je les ai vus jouer il n'y a pas si
longtemps et leur voix se mélange toujours
très très bien bien sûr ils faisaient
l'original  matériel donc comme note disant à
quoi ressembleraient les chansons mais magh
quand la voix est vraiment très bonne je l'ai
vu prendre une douche et il avait de nouvelles
chansons qui étaient vraiment bonnes
donc je veux dire ne dit-on pas
qu'il pourrait faire un  enregistrer ce
serait bien, il est un parallèle entre
quelqu'un que j'ai mangé ma zone et certains de vos
trucs en altitude peut-être se terminer et
il n'y a rien à utiliser ces gens
qui disent que d'une manière ou d'une autre ils
faisaient cette meilleure musique quand ils
faisaient comme si les oiseaux étaient les Beatles et
tout ça, c'est pourquoi vous utilisez et la
musique était meilleure que n'importe quelle autre maintenant non, je
ne pense pas que vous utilisiez simplement les gens
parce que vous savez qu'ils sont des
instrumentistes intelligents et que vous entendez quelque chose
dans la façon dont ils abordent leur
instrument, ce scandale, vous savez que c'est
un morceau de leur
légende en les utilisant, c'est une erreur de
penser même de cette façon et pour quiconque, toute
personne critique ou même auditeur d'
imaginer que c'est ce que j'entends  pense que
c'est incorrect parce que c'est l'
intention de les utiliser simplement à cause
de la façon dont ils abordent leur
instrument correctement, donc t-bone Burnett
implique toujours très fortement la production
et le place dans le four
alors oui qu'est-ce qui est plein d'une relation l
pourquoi  eh bien il a une très bonne idée de la
façon dont les chansons devraient aller il a une très bonne
façon de il a une sorte de dispositif de repérage sur
le sens et l'âme d'une chanson que
certains producteurs ont tendance à perdre dans la
machinerie du  studio en ce sens qu'il a tendance
à maintenir une relation avec la
notion originale de la chanson et vos
sentiments personnels à ce sujet, comme si je
pense qu'il part du point de vue
de savoir ce que la personne ressent à propos
du matériel et qu'il est doué pour se
rappeler  s'ils sont
distraits au cours de la création d'un
disque, il y a deux choses que
vous savez impliquées, il y a l'écriture
de la chanson et puis il y a la réalisation
du disque et les deux choses ne sont pas
toujours compatibles parfois vous ne  ça ne
sert pas le sens de la chanson parce que
tu tombes amoureux d'un son qui
ici dans le studio et il est très bon
pour te rappeler quelle était ton
intention initiale et pourquoi tu voulais chanter
la chanson en premier lieu d'autre
part Kevin  kill et l'autre producteur
a pu s'occuper de tirer le meilleur
parti des différents sons que nous avions, nous avions donc un bon équilibre entre quelqu'un qui
comprenait la musique et vous comment la
rendre vivante et quelque chose  ody qui a compris
le sens de la musique et toi quand
on s'en éloignait si jamais on l'a
fait ça parle d'un sens de
l'album et tes intentions originales
sont très directement politiques / probablement
plus directes que beaucoup d'œuvres précédentes
et je  Je ne pense pas que
certaines chansons soient interprétées de cette
façon, mais dans l'ensemble, le disque est une
collection de 15 chansons avec
des attitudes et des sujets différents Je
ne vois pas comment vous savez où est l'
intention politique et bébé joue
bien je veux dire  il y a vérifier les
légumes et les vêtements il y a un cœur
je veux dire il y a parfois c'est plus mince
dans certaines pistes peut-être que j'ai mais je
ne vois pas la politique est séparée de la
vie tout cela fait partie de la vie c'est les disques à
peu près peu à des aspects de
mais j'ai ressenti ou vu au cours de la
période où j'écrivais des
chansons et dans une autre année ou aussi
longtemps qu'il me faudra pour faire un autre disque,
il y aura d'autres choses qui me préoccuperont
mais c'est n  ce n'est pas une condition absolue
toute chanson écrite là-bas n'est pas une
condition absolue ce n'est pas tout ce que j'ai
à dire ou à penser à quelque chose parce que
tout comme quelqu'un qui entend la chanson ici,
c'est dans un sens un jour et le lendemain,
ils ont entendu d'une autre manière bien je  Je ressens la
même chose à chaque fois que je dis un de ces
sons dont ils changent le
sens c'était un peu mais c'est le plus
aimé les paroles sont très directes et quand
vous nommez les noms à la fin
des chansons vous dites d'accord  c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça et c'est bien
ouais c'est tout ce qu'il y a à dire je
veux dire c'est qu'il n'y a rien de
plus pour amender la chanson dans ce sens
sauf de la rechanter avec un
accent différent mais il n'y a rien de plus  s'il
voulait en dire plus, je l'aurais
mis dans la chanson, vous comprenez ce que je veux
dire et si vous écrivez toujours une autre chanson
à un stade ultérieur, c'est ce que je
ressens maintenant pour changer mes sentiments ou
quelque chose de la même manière que tout le monde a
son toi  kn  ow le droit et ils peuvent
avoir la volonté de changer leur propre vie
et de changer la façon dont les choses sont en faisant
quelque chose au lieu de simplement se
plaindre et sur la même ligne, je
pensais que cette chose était vraiment expressive
peut-être encore plus expressive
qu'avant je  je ne sais pas que cela l'a bien expliqué de
mon mieux que j'espère certainement
que c'est le cas évidemment vous espérez que
vous vous rapprochez du sens que vous
avez vraiment parfois vous obtenez ce
peu de distance dans le
studio la technologie de la manière  vous entendez des
choses que vous obtenez dans un état d'esprit
différent de l'état d'esprit
dans lequel vous étiez lorsque vous avez écrit la chanson et
vous perdez en quelque sorte l'essence de la chanson
en cours de route, eh bien, je ne pense pas que cela se soit
produit ce matin  et c'est en partie
dû au fait que je fais
ça depuis 12 ans et je sais ce que je
fais maintenant et en partie parce
que j'ai eu de bonnes personnes qui travaillaient avec moi
qui m'ont aidé à arriver au point où vous savez
non  peu importe combien  les instruments jouent sur
l'album mais il n'y a qu'autant de
notes sur l'album Azure censé
parler d'une époque et d'un âge que vous zonez
le fait que vous obtenez tout cela un
changement dans vos écrits et sur des choses comme la
politique eh bien vous vous levez soudainement c'est  pourquoi
je pense que l'Iran les dirigera
pour bien non je ne pense pas que ce soit vrai
parce qu'il y a des chansons que les gens
ont interprétées comme politiques qui
parlent d'autre chose que de dire des choses
du cœur sur lesquelles j'écris
depuis que j'ai commencé tout d'abord  le disque que j'ai jamais
sorti était dans le dossier politique de Deborah
moins de zéro tous ses
interprètes d'armées dossiers politiques Je
fais ça depuis le début vous juste vous
excluez tous les autres sentiments et toutes les
autres expériences de votre vie de votre
écriture alors vous devenez comme  une
personne analytique plutôt froide qui ne regarde la
politique que comme quelque chose que vous gardez dans
une boîte comme du mastic idiot que vous sortez
et moulez en formes pour amuser les gens afin
qu'ils puissent avoir  la conscience d'un accident vasculaire cérébral
vous savez pour qu'ils n'aient pas à
penser par eux-mêmes vous savez que nous avons des
gens en prison quelque part quelque part
dans une partie du monde terriblement impressionnante
pour que d'autres personnes puissent se tenir dans un
stade de football et agiter leurs bras
à propos de vous savez facile, je ne vais pas faire une
chose de piste de chapitre mais dites-moi que je ne suis pas
familier avec la politique anglaise, que ce
soit des chansons du Bengale sur l'
angle de la terre est une histoire est une histoire vraie le
cas qui s'est produit en 1952 et bien
sans  racontant l'histoire de la chanson
et le gars a été pendu pour quelque chose
qu'il n'a pas fait et c'est l'un de ces cas qui
a été
soulevé et rappelé chaque fois que le débat
sur la peine capitale est évoqué
et j'ai lu une interview avec
la sœur de l'homme qui était très émouvante
parce qu'elle a approché cela
30 ans plus tard de plus de 30 ans
plus tard, essayant toujours d'obtenir une
reconnaissance de l'erreur qui a été
commise presque certainement peut-être juste l  m'a
demandé d'écrire la chanson, je veux dire que cela
ne va évidemment rien accomplir
en soi par rapport à l'affaire, mais
c'est un très bon exemple de la raison pour laquelle c'est
mal d'avoir la peine capitale à mon
avis et aussi cela fait un commentaire sur le
fait qu'il  il me semble qu'il est utilisé
de temps en temps comme un dispositif politique
pour distraire les gens d'autres préoccupations
c'est ce que disent les notes finales de la chanson
ne l'enfilons pas l'idée
que quand c'est pratique ce sont
certaines personnes d'une certaine
persuasion politique  apportera le
débat aggravera le débat sur
la peine capitale parce que c'est
politiquement utile pour eux de détourner les
gens d'autres cartes probablement
des questions plus importantes parce que c'est une sorte de
c'est une sorte d'argument inutile vraiment
il a déjà été prouvé que ce n'est
pas le cas  ne dissuadez pas l'argent dedans et
dites que des erreurs peuvent être commises,
comme celle décrite dans la chanson, c'est juste
utilisé comme un dispositif de distraction à mon
avis, donc du divertissement  quelle est votre
définition du divertissement qu'est-ce que la
nourriture de divertissement aucune idée et
artiste avec qui étaient vos grands
artistes je veux dire, je sais que vous
avez parlé de gens comme
non couverts alors je vous déteste dans les
interviews faisant référence à Kuala comme
jouer certains de  ces disques et tout ça
n'étaient certainement pas Henry et Howard lâches je
pense que peut-être maintenant il n'y avait plus de Carol
oh chérie aucune voiture n'était Henry et je suis le
père des chats tu sais que j'entendrai des
radiations nous jouions danser j'ai
vraiment apprécié le  des chansons et des trucs euh
bien donc je veux dire tu parles de nous Oh
spike c'est quoi son nom vraiment tu sais
spike jeune malgré le rocher ouais
bien par les Bulldogs très bien ouais il a
dit quelque chose je suis venu pour le titre
de cette chanson ouais donc de toute façon je veux dire  la
loi toutes les chansons je suis vraiment une sorte
de cabaret dans le traitement
je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire je veux dire quand
sur ces jouer à moitié sur l'absurde et
faire comme même jusqu'à l'arrangement du
genre quand tu débrasse l'arrange  ments aussi
bien vous pourriez vous lancer comme cela peut
se produire assez cabaret comme signifiant les gens
je ne connais pas de cabaret nous pouvons aller
entendre cette musique jouée je pense que c'est un
cabaret de l'imagination partie cool à
souffrir il y a beaucoup d'orchestration
exactement vous  Je ne peux pas entendre cette musique, je veux dire,
je suppose que ce truc persiste en
arrière-plan, cela fait partie d'un souvenir de
tout ce que vous emportez avec vous lorsque
vous faites un enregistrement de toutes les choses que vous
écoutez pour avoir une influence sur la façon dont
vous abordez l'arrangement  du
disque mais rien n'est une
influence de Donnan je pense sur le son du
disque je ne ressens rien je ne pense pas
qu'il ait une la comparaison est au-delà d'une
ressemblance passagère comme vous savez
voir quelqu'un dans le  rue qui
te rappelle ton oncle ou quelque chose de
bien tu vas vraiment aimer quand
t'impliquer tu libères un véhicule du
brûleur à oignons qui était comme encore comme
quand j'étais comme ouais c'était sur mon label
j'avais rien à faire  avec la
fabrication  de celui-ci, j'aime que vous l'ayez montré
la façon dont la façon de montrer se
présente et des trucs c'est très bien d'
accord Braverman est entre se lever
et ensuite juste un chanteur régulier mmm
des parties de ce que je fais tu sais essayer  pour
étendre le contexte de la chanson
en expliquant certains détails de
la chanson d'une manière et je suppose qu'il y a
une intention de satire sur les
éléments lamer du show business dans la
couverture du disque et c'est une partie de la
mise en scène qui  Je l'ai utilisé mais ce n'est pas une
chose constante c'est plutôt comme vous savez
l'idée que certaines des chansons sont
politiques comme là-dedans gravées dans la pierre
et pas la même chose pour la
présentation de l'utilisation de l'
instrumentation ce n'est pas une
chose constante vous  Je ne pouvais pas acheter la couleur de l'
album rapidement,
c'était bien ça, donc comme il semble, je veux dire que j'ai
été peint de cette façon et j'ai passé la tête à
travers ce trou dans le mur et
c'était tout et c'était long et
processus douloureux que j'ai subi pour mon ar  t maintenant
c'est ton tour bien
concept l'idée c'était une sorte de
combinaison de certaines images que j'avais l'
air avec Jerry intensifié ils
sont réalisateurs chez Warner Brothers qui ont mis
la chose plusieurs idées différentes et nous nous sommes en
quelque sorte assis ensemble et avons eu  cette
notion ensemble nommée brian Griffin et
son équipe l'a photographié
et photographié la chose que j'ai dit bien une
des choses que je fais vous fait vraiment vraiment
vous fait aimer les myers en ce qui concerne
les produits de divertissement certains films vous
ne savez rien rien vous
ne savez rien  et vient immédiatement à l'esprit
comme étant essentiel, il y a certains que vous
connaissez des routines et des lignes et des choses qui
vous semblent très précises
en décembre dans la satire de la façon
dont ils se moquent d'une certaine fragilité humaine
que vous pouvez toujours leur rendre  même s'ils
ne le font pas, vous ne trouvez pas drôle de la
même manière que la première fois que vous avez
entendu qu'ils le touchent toujours de cette façon,
vous savez, je pense que la bonne comédie a cela en
elle  mais qu'est-ce que je sais, je ne suis pas un comédien
sur le même puits que vous avez essayé, vous aviez été
communautaire sans capitulation, c'était encore une fois,
c'était fou et bien j'étais un magicien ce
qui est un peu différent c'est un peu
comme un musicien seulement vous le dites
différemment  mais encore une fois, il y avait un
artiste ouais mais c'est juste une
coïncidence, je veux dire que c'était la
coïncidence de l'unité de casting, donc
retourner Tyler jouer avec des lapins et vous
savez revenir aux origines de
certains de cette maison, vous vous sentez proche de
quelqu'un comme  Tom Waits, je veux dire, vous utilisez
certains de ses musiciens, mais moi de
là-bas, j'aime les arrangements et
j'aime vraiment la musique de Tom Waits.
vous savez que les membres de
son fan ont joué sur mon disque et j'ai entendu des
choses qu'ils ont faites avec dans ses disques
et ses émissions
je pouvais imaginer qu'ils travailleraient en
collaboration avec d'autres personnes mais ce
n'était pas  à tel point qu'ils ont apporté tout un
ensemble de sons avec eux, vous savez
qu'ils ont apporté leur attitude, leur
approche de leur instrument, une réverbération intelligente,
en particulier au guitariste.
Je l'avais aussi entendu jouer avec le
lézard de salon, donc je l'avais entendu dans différents
contextes.  et aussi sur disque en jouant de
la musique classique, donc vous savez que j'étais conscient
de l'étendue de la pièce que Michael Blair a
jouée sur King of America, par exemple,
il a joué sur l'un des camions klaxonnant
d'un moteur à côté, ce n'est pas
exclusivement dû à cela, vous savez que j'admire  mais je ne
pense pas que tu saches que c'est là que la
connexion se termine vraiment la semaine je pense que sa
musique est merveilleuse mais je ne cherche pas à l'
imiter il est aussi un grand toi
de ta femme oui elle aime sa musique
aussi toi  ouais juste quelqu'un d'autre avec qui
vous collaborez pendant que vous avez pris de
l'obscurité en gros vérifier Baker j'ai
pris de l'obscurité je pense qu'il non je
ne suis pas d'accord je veux dire ils il était où
où qu'il soit il était là et y est
resté je l'ai fait  ne le prends pas de toute façon, je
veux dire qu'il est venu et a joué sur mon
disque, puis j'ai collaboré avec lui
à une autre occasion et peu de temps
avant sa mort, Lee a enregistré une de mes
cellules qui est dans le film, perdons-nous
ce qui est très  beau morceau de
film triste mais j'étais sur le point de poser des questions sur les
développements de tout, voyez-vous
pécheur oui et c'est le
point de vue particulier d'une personne sur Chet Baker, je
veux dire qu'il sert les conceptions artistiques de Bruce Weber
autant qu'il sert la musique JPEG
je ne le fais pas  pense vraiment que cela sert
complètement la musique des cerises, je ne pense pas que ce
soit un mauvais service, mais il se concentre
presque exclusivement sur son chant pour
une chose et la façon dont il avait l'air et les
manifestations étaient vous savez de son look
et ce qu'il représente deux
personnes différentes et  sa relation avec ses
amis famille copines et ainsi de suite
ce n'est pas vraiment un c'est un portrait d'une
personne en désintégration c'est ce
qu'il semble être plutôt que d'un
musicien comme de telles musiques ki  nd d'
Andale avez-vous aimé la version de la
construction navale que devrait faire son fils
je ne suis pas au courant qu'il ait jamais chanté une version
de la construction navale il a chanté une version de
presque soufflé Oh mosman Sania oui eh bien je
veux dire c'est une chanson que j'ai écrite
en pensant à lui et je le lui ai donné au moment
où il est venu jouer sur la construction navale mais
je n'avais aucune idée qu'il l'avait enregistré
jusqu'à sa mort, vous savez que je ne l'ai
reçu que quelques mois de lui et
et c'est un  magnifique, vous savez, c'est une
interprétation très profonde du Soleil et aussi
un morceau de film très déchirant à cause
de ce qui pour moi était l'
indifférence familière du public à ce
qu'il tentait de faire J'avais vu ça dans
des clubs de jazz mais bien sûr c'est  quelque peu
exagéré car cela le trahit en
train de chanter la chanson au Festival de
Cannes où il y a beaucoup de
fêtards ivres vous savez qui essaient de faire une sorte de
fête sur sa musique qui n'est pas vraiment
très appropriée vous savez et si vous l'avez
vu vous savez qu'il  20 tentatives pour les
faire taire b  y chanter la chanson et
c'est assez déchirant quelques minutes
pour la soirée pouvez-vous faire la fête pour terminer
cette musique de Castellan dépend de quelle
chanson il s'agit n'est-ce pas vous savez je veux dire
là je ne sais pas ce que ce mot
signifie c'est un peu  comme vous savez, c'est
un de ces mots qui a été dévalué
par la répétition, je veux dire, vous pouvez
danser certaines chansons d'accord, mais ce n'est
pas l'intention principale d'eux, évidemment,
vous savez que j'ai créé des choses
à dire des mélodies à chanter, ils
ont tous  Bill, vous savez, a frappé les gens de
différentes manières J'ai fait des disques
autant que possible pour rebondir, mais c'est une chance que
cela n'ait jamais été mon âme et ma principale
considération lorsque j'ai approché un
tracteur pour être dansant Je ne me souviens pas avoir
dit que nous ferions mieux de faire ça
dansant c'est un heureux accident si
le rythme peut essayer de le faire aussi
c'est génial vous savez que les gens peuvent rebondir
sur vous pouvez passer à tous les types de musique que
vous voyez Je rejette l'idée que la
musique de danse doit être si raide voyez-vous  Je
préférerais danser à l'équipe de jonglerie, je voudrais
aussi que vous sachiez que beaucoup de
musique de danse était appelée musique de danse.
vous demandez à la
mauvaise personne à propos de la musique rebondissante, [ __ ] de musique de
danse, ça sonne complètement
stupidement rythmiquement ennuyeux parce que
c'est parce que c'est /
ordinateur mais encore une fois beaucoup d'
artistes d'enregistrement semblent trouver une copie papier du fait
que la plupart de la musique maintenant  est de la
musique de danse et il y en a ce n'est pas de la
musique de danse même si c'est juste que c'est juste
rigide vous savez que c'est un peu rigide c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de rythme humain pour que la
danse exige des personnes âgées et que les muscles
et les tendons bougent et vous savez que vous êtes
forçant votre corps à une
rigidité anormale et le deuxième fils de cela
est beaucoup d'artistes d'enregistrement J'ai
demandé l'aide de musiciens africains
musiciens asiatiques comment n'appelleront-ils pas cela de
la musique du monde parce que d'une manière ou d'une autre tout t  hé ils ont
été perdus dans leurs manières oh le truc
eh bien cette musique est trop forte nous devons en
faire quelque chose peut nous avoir
parce que les rythmes et ils
n'ont pas tellement formulé le rythme
tu sais que je le pense  les arias la somme
des signatures temporelles qui sont jouées dans une
paire de musique en particulier sont
suffisamment inhabituelles pour que le
pouls dans lequel nous nous sommes enracinés au
fil des années, cela sonne très vivant
et cela et pour vous savez les oreilles du Moyen-Orient
cela peut sembler que nous avons absolument une
machine comme un disque d'Aitken Waterman
, vous savez comme si vous pouviez frapper,
vous savez la musique bulgare rapide par opposition
à la musique chorale qu'ils jouent toutes
sortes de l'avion 1712 ou quelque chose que vous
savez qu'ils jouent du vrai  des
signatures temporelles étranges mais ce n'est pas une
affectation ce n'est pas comme regarder un
groupe de jazz fusion essayer de jouer à cette
époque pour prouver un point qu'ils
prévoient naturellement que dans ces
signatures de type étranges et les impulsions sont parfaitement
normales dit  c'était là frais parce que
nous étions en quelque sorte épuisés pour l'automne, vous savez
et avez tendance à vous faire n'importe quelle entreprise
intègre cela à votre musique, il y a des
choses en vous savez que
je dois le mettre comme une couche de
placage que vous pouvez incorporer dans très
des manières subtiles tout au long de 12 ans de ce
dans quoi je travaille, il y a des choses dont j'entends juste des
bribes Je ne pense pas que vous deviez
aller à cet endroit et
vous y baptiser afin de vous rendre
crédible Je n'ai pas besoin  l'approbation de quiconque
dans la façon dont j'entends les choses si j'entends
quelque chose, je pourrais l'absorber et le
synthétiser d'une manière que vous ne
reconnaîtrez jamais vous savez si je vous disais
que ce n'est pas ce disque mais le
disque précédent avait une référence à notre
disque vada alors  vous savez seriez-vous
capable de dire quelle piste c'était long je
ne pense pas parce que c'était une
référence passagère vous savez à un disque égyptien
que j'ai entendu dire que j'utilise un peu
de rythme vous pouvez le faire vous savez vous
peut l'utiliser de manière intéressante
et  ça ne doit pas être tu ne dois pas
te montrer tu sais tu ne dois pas
être tu sais je ne dis pas que les
gens qui font ça sont mauvais ça ne
me concerne pas que j'ai besoin de l'approbation des gens
mais  Je suis avec la dernière
tendance dont c'est comme si c'était comme si les
gens ne partaient en vacances que dans des endroits
dont personne d'autre n'avait entendu parler, vous savez
et vous avez dit que je n'étais plus à l'aise du roi d'
Amérique que vous tuiez Alice
Costello la marque  dans une certaine mesure, je
pense que c'est vrai, je pense que les gens
reconnaissent si vous lisez des articles qui sont
écrits sur ce que j'ai fait, que ce soit en
direct, généralement mentionné dans une
variété de noms, les gens ont reconnu
qu'il y a la distinction entre
le personnage qui était tri  d'un
soi-disant défini par, disons, les quatre
ou cinq premiers albums que j'ai faits et la
personne qui opère aujourd'hui, vous savez que nous
ne vous avons pas vu devant une caméra
devant des journaux que leur modem dans
votre propre couverture de spin ce mois-ci a obtenu  une
pierre roulante la plupart des c  beaucoup je
voulais que le magazine britannique tu fasses des
interviews télévisées alors pourquoi tu veux dire pourquoi
serais-je sur la couverture que quand je
ne faisais rien je veux dire vraiment
tu ne fais que des choses comme ça je tu sais
que ce n'est pas un processus naturel pour  être
interviewé sur des choses que je veux dire je
ne peux pas avoir j'ai une sortie automatique
de tout ce que je vous dis pourrait être
complètement mentir parce que c'est ce que je
n'ai pas rempli
et je pourrais me lever demain et dire bien en
fait je pense complètement  le pays
à cela parce que c'est un
processus naturel de pardon, vous savez alerter les
gens sur le fait qu'il y a un disque
là-bas qui pourrait intéresser et qu'il y en a
beaucoup plus dans les racks, vous savez
qu'il y a d'autres types de musique et comme
vous l'avez souligné, il y a de la musique de  partout
dans le monde, c'est intéressant et
il y a de la musique de loin dans le
temps qui est intéressante et il y a de la
musique qui sort aujourd'hui qui est
intéressante c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est le commandant
qui n'est pas intéressant, je veux dire que c'est
tout un énorme  des choses et c'est à l'
individu de déterminer ce dont il a
besoin mais je fais ces choses et vous savez que cela
ne représente rien pour moi
sauf que c'est une alerte c'est comme une petite
lumière pour dire aux gens où c'est vous
savez qu'il est  beaucoup de choses pour
vous guider à travers ces jours et vous avez eu
une relation vraiment vallonnée avec
l'industrie de la musique au cours des 10 dernières années,
ils ont une relation vallonnée avec moi,
je n'ai aucun problème avec vous si
excitant dans le monde WEA et  comme obtenir
quelque chose, c'est l'une des conséquences,
tout à coup, vos disques en lui américains
s'installent être un succès en euro ouais eh bien je veux dire
que rien n'arrêtait en fait que l'
Amérique soit frappée en Amérique parce que
j'étais avec une grande maison de disques pendant 10
ans et je  a eu divers degrés de
succès et divers degrés de
satisfaction et, évidemment, avec un nouvel
élan et un nouvel enthousiasme, pas de vieilles
batailles à revendre, il est beaucoup
plus facile de vous faire connaître tout au long du
processus de sortie d'un disque  et
alerter les gens sur le fait qu'il
existe et de quoi il s'agit et essayer d'
expliquer le contexte et essayer de corriger
certains des malentendus à ce sujet, mais
vraiment c'est tout ce que je peux
déduire d'être sur une grande maison de
disques qu'ils ont fait  un bon travail par le
disque mais pourquoi pas c'est un bon disque alors
où est le disque sur le point de
revenir pour revenir à cela désolé alors de quoi
parle le disque s'il n'y en a pas,
je ne pourrais pas le résumer en  une phrase désinvolte que vous connaissez,
je n'essaierais pas de faire
ça pour l'enregistrement de qui que ce soit et
j'espère que l'essentiel est que ce soit un
enregistrement de vous connaissez différentes pensées
différents sentiments différentes
observations différents types de musique
que j'utilise pour éclairer ces choses
et c'est  à chaque personne de réagir
aux chansons je ne peux pas leur dire comment penser
alors tu as n'est pas mon travail tu vas
déménager uniquement à Dublin tu as à Londres
mais probablement bien où tu le fais je veux dire tu
sais
dans  comme te regarder ne t'aime pas
comme Londres pas beaucoup de temps eh bien qu'est-ce qui
t'attire pour lui jeter une île
eh bien j'ai une maison là-bas tu sais c'est
un peu plus d'espace quelque part tu
sais quelque part je peux faire un bruit qui
agace les voisins d'accord d'accord